you can imagine when we want to boost
our well-being we often seek out these
really beautiful places but the problem
is how do you measure these beautiful
places and that's not been an easy thing
to do so luckily I came across this
website and this is online game people
play and it's really simple you just
rate these images between 1 and 10
what's happening in the background is
that each image represents a square
kilometer of the United Kingdom so I've
got like over 200,000 images have been
weighted about 1.5 million times
so I'm using a ZURB to train my deep
learning models because I really need
GPU access what's really great about
using azor is that I can train models in
a matter of days which normally would
take months on my desktop say our
research also seeks to measure aspects
of the world that we as humans have
always been hugely aware of but that
traditionally we've had near to no
numbers on I think an excellent example
of this is the beauty of environments
that we spend our time in so I think
many of us have this impression that
like something which can have a real
impact on our day-to-day well-being so
we do find that people are happier in
these more beautiful environment and
they can be these beautiful natural
scenes but I was really surprised to
find that people are also happier in
more beautiful city environments and
people actually do find buildings as
being beautiful as well
so I'm really excited about the
possibilities of data science because I
strongly believe that data science will
change the world for the better
[Music]